there you go buddy Coco nice right
oh good root gang you better cop Chuck T
thank you so much to the coco beats to
Dad's head go parent teen on lockdown
this year we're gonna spend one
Christmas well all together what until
their dad
this guy's crazy your kids have the
funds into town and why cane - we're
back more daddy
we got a big surprise it's even better
this year no more back and forth that
Christmas is not 2 in the back of note
they just said that
but together Christmas like a normal
family has a Christmas hello grandpa
Kurt my dad is gonna scoff at everything
you do your father hasn't met the new of
all dusty I mean who wouldn't be
impressed with you man dear God it's
gonna come off weird dusty but he's
beautiful
why don't you bring the car around I'm
not the driver I'm Brad stepdad my dad's
coming to sweater he wears a red sweater
so I can see him in a crowd so this coat
dad's thing you gotta ask another man's
permission to see your own kit
everything is rock-solid between me and
bread in fact best friends really bad
thank you stop it oh good cuz we're boys
don't get the girls thing here's the
game plan
you won't be that one that she tells you
about all of her problems with the guys
she's actually dating it's called the
friendzone no go know the worst advice
anyone could give you you want to be
like Brad and me in the friend zone you
want to be like dad and get the end zone
oh gosh that's piercing eyes like a
velociraptor don't you see what he's up
to
you think she'll be a harpy and - no I'm
not harboring anything I just want to
find the perfect together Christmas tree
you don't think I can operate a chainsaw
[Music]
don't you want to spend the harness the
one true real dad got a long way up here
just to get back in it
yep they opening up the heart of brass
wall and the heart was wide open and
it's Fleet Week this is getting good
boys you throw that we are no longer
code dad's you got a pump fake that
thing all night you gonna take a shot
Brad huh he's never played sports ever
what what maybe it stuck to his hand
[Applause]
what does you know what
[Applause]
you